now what do you do when people come to
you and they're on antidepressants well
I have a book called spontaneous
happiness which is about emotional
wellness is a lot there about
antidepressants first of all they don't
work so well you know that's very
sometimes they work sometimes it's hard
to distinguish them from placebos right
no the popular ones the SSRIs
yeah and now because they don't work so
well you know what doctors do they add
one they added a psychotic drug yeah
I'm horrifying these are like four major
mental illness they're not things you
just add on to make the other depressant
work better we've talked about that one
ad nauseam on this podcast flood because
it turned out to be the most prescribed
drug America I can't believe it that's
just astounding
well the word is that 25% of women
between 40 and 50 are on antidepressants
and 10% of adults in the country all
right now here's another that's a crazy
number well first of all the
pharmaceutical companies have done a
great job of convincing people that
ordinary states of sadness are problems
of brain biochemistry that yeah it's
easy with a drug we're not supposed to
be happy all right secondly there's a
big problem with a lot of the
medications that we use in
antidepressants are a good example most
of the medications we use are
counteractive you know they opposed some
process in the bar right so when you do
that the body pushes back against it
that's called homeostasis you know an
easy example you can relate to is if you
have a stuffed up nose you spray a drug
in it that decongest you miraculous
right you can breathe and depending on
which drug you use two hours four hours
at last but when it wears off you have
rebound congestion that's worse if you
use another dose of the drug then very
easy to slide in Jamie very easy to
slide into a state of dependence on it
same thing happens with many of these
drugs antidepressants they raise
serotonin levels at neural junction
neural junction so what is the body
going to do if you force an increase in
serotonin it's gonna make less serotonin
and drop serotonin receptors so if you
stay in one of these for any length of
time when you get off it you're gonna be
in worse shape than you were to begin
with and this is now has a medical name
it's called tardive
dysphoria meaning lingering bad mood due
to the drug so the drug actually
prolongs or intensifies the depression
you know maybe okay for very short term
use of very severe depression but these
are not things you want to go on and
stay on for a length of time what's
fascinating to me is when I talk to
people that are on them that want to
talk to you like they're on some cancer
medication or they're on you know
something that cures polio yeah like
they make it seem like you're
insensitive to the possibility that
there's other solutions right and there
are many other solutions we have really
good evidence for the antidepressant
effect of physical activity yes both to
prevent and treat yeah we have very good
evidence for supplemental fish oil for
omega-3 fatty acids to prevent in CDs
well oh and the microbiome looks like
it's involved in our mental states as
well so you know there's so many
different ways yes CBD for sure so again
gets back to information pick Anna gets
back to in an integrative approach and
not just relying on a single thing like
a pharmaceutical treatment yeah I've
talked to intelligent people that are on
SSRIs in one form or another and even
ones that have struggled we're on one
for awhile and it stopped working and
then they tried another one and they're
compounding ones and they're on this
weird sort of chemical rollercoaster and
they reject any possible notion that
there's other alternatives especially
when you bring up the exercise one right
I bring up the exercise one they go oh
this [ __ ] meathead exercise we just
stopped I'm like I'm telling you we did
this thing with my friends called sober
October and what we did is we no alcohol
no anything for the month of October but
also we did this fitness challenge and
we got real carried away and we're all
competing against each other with this
heart rate app so we're working out
three hours four hours a day was crazy
but what was interesting about it to me
was not just that your body sort of
adapts when you force it to work out
that many hours but that your mood is
phenomenal yeah I felt so good yeah and
I was telling everybody if you could
take what I like I don't feel that good
right now okay I mean I feel great but I
don't feel as good as I did during
October because I was working out four
hours a day it was if you could get that
in pill form you would take it every day
if there was no side effects because it
literally removed anxiety all the
internal chatter all the negative
chatter it was gone
everything seemed amazing true and there
are side effects of physical activity
are great you know it revs up immune
function improves digestion asleep all
that you mentioned anxiety the by far in
a way the most effective treatment I
found for anxiety is simple a simple
breathing technique no regulating the
breath I've seen this work for the most
extreme forms of panic disorder and the
drugs that we use for anxiety are the
worst the benzodiazepines highly
addictive mess with your mind yeah I
have a good friend who has an issue with
anxiety medication and he takes it all
the time and when he doesn't take it
apparently it has that rebound effect
exactly right he gets horribly anxious
well these are handed out like candy and
nobody warns people how addictive they
are it's a worse addiction than an
opiate addiction it Zanic yeah really
yeah yep why I did not know that harder
to get off of than opioids Wow